as you don't
void
ad hominem this is attacking your
opponent rather than your opponents
arguments now the thing I love about
this is on the internet people make a
big deal out of the distinction between
calling someone names is a way of
refuting their arguments and calling
someone names just as kind of a hobby a
little sidetrack if you will so for
instance saying you provide oral
pleasure to nutria thus you're wrong is
bad that's a fallacy but saying you
provide oral pleasure to nutria and
you're wrong is okey kosher these are
the sort of careful distinctions that
keep internet arguments burning like an
Olympic torch that never leaves the
house be straw man fallacy now this is
when an opponent attacks an argument
that's not the argument you are actually
making so anytime your opponent says
anything because if they're responding
to the argument you're actually making
they'd be agreeing with you so for
instance you might say Emily Dickinson
was this guy in palos verdes who sold
bicycle parts and your opponent might
say now actually Emily Dickinson was a
woman poet from New England and you can
say straw man i'm not talking about
women from New England I'm talking about
Emily Dickinson this can be used with
any argument as long as you're stupid
enough d plus begging the question this
is also known as using the wrong phrase
because nobody ever uses begging the
question correctly you can use this to
your advantage because when you use the
phrase nobody can contradict you so they
say it hailing mud is bad for your
health that's begging the question the
moon is very far away that's begging the
question you just keep repeating the
same thing over and over again ahh
begging the question I'm going to hire
someone to kill you in front of your
family up begging the question the only
possible defense against this is to say
that when you say begging the question
that itself is begging the question and
then you and your opponent can kind of
go back and forth like that and
eventually the Sun explodes c-minus
false dichotomy this is when you say
that there are only two choices when
actually there are more for instance you
might say that someone is either alive
or they're dead ignoring the fact that
they might be Dracula or you might say
that if someone's not a Democrat then
they must be some sort of Republican
ignoring the very real possibility that
they could be Dracula the most common
usage of this fallacy is in the phrase
you're either with us or against us
Dracula Dracula's against you be-